[Musique]
c'est reparti pour la loire à vélo les
mains sur le guidon
les cyclotouristes sont de retour après
un confinement éprouvant ces dernières
semaines ont réveillé des envies de
prendre le large et de profiter des
paysages de la région après le
déconfinement près de 20 % de plus par
rapport à mai 2009 sont venus faire du
vélo visiter les bords de loire les
châteaux les différents endroits aller
dans un endroit naturel le mois de juin
a été un mois plus difficiles bien
évidemment les conditions climatiques
ont été moins facile mais si vous êtes
vous voyez aujourd'hui en venant ici il
y avait à nouveau beaucoup de touristes
français et étrangers
les étrangers ne se font pas prier pour
revenir comme chez ce loueur de vélos
installés à brimont l'un des seuls entre
tous et souvenirs depuis l'ouverture des
frontières j'ai des belges des
hollandais des allemands des suisses
et bien sûr on va dire des australiens
des américains
enfin la clientèle étrangère reviens moi
c'est 70% de mon budget vous avez un
petit panneau
des étrangers mais pas seulement
les français aussi re découvre les
trésors de la loire on avait fait les
quelques châteaux en voiture moustiques
c'était plus sympa à vélo et enfin du
constant dans cette vente se remettre un
peu ouverte et même les locaux ont
décidé de s'approprier cet itinéraire on
habite au bord de la loire à vélo donc
en fait on voit tous les jours des vélos
par dizaines par centaines passé et on
se dit pourquoi pas nous ce serait sympa
de partir en famille faire une petite
virée sur quelques jours sur dix jours
en l'occurrence la loire à vélo on peut
la faire très sportivement ou bien
simplement avec les enfants c'est super
d'aller dans la nature avec les enfants
leur faire découvrir
du coup la région et puis de faire du
sport de voir la nature
il adore c'est la première fois qu'on le
fait ils sont mordus pourquoi un vélo
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est dingue était
dans la carriole mais qui veut plus y
être
véritable vitrine de la région la loire
à vélo attire chaque année un peu plus
d'un million de cyclotouristes les
produits 34 millions d'euros de
retombées économiques
[Musique]